I know everyone's gonna say I'm pissing
all over Richard but it really is
disturbing his Halloween fascination and
it's not a stick it's like Wow will who
works here and Richard who works here
they moved next to each other and he
ended up taking the train with Richard
every day and he goes richard sits there
with halloween themed magazines what are
those they're like magazines for
housewives I want to say but they're how
all Halloween themed it says here
richard has the Women's Day Halloween
edition magnet that's what it is Richard
and his wife spent three nights at
Halloween Horror Nights in Florida they
went to multiple haunted houses they
left their son at home I mean what the
[ __ ] are you up to dude livin life
Richard also has a 30 hour long
Halloween sound effects playlist on his
iPhone which by the way he listens to
when you're on the train with him right
yes well it's funny cuz now like we
can't ride the same train car home
because we'll sits in the quiet car yeah
and I get yelled at in the quiet car
because the screaming that comes my
headphones why are you wearing your
headphones so hot I'm half-deaf really
yeah Wow
I turn mine up at full blast oh dear
what do you have on Halloween right now
candy corn
boxers Halloween socks Halloween
phonecase oh my god
a guy complimenting my pumpkin hat this
morning have you seen his house yes it's
covered in Halloween crap I bought like
this mega pack of fake cobwebs and
covered our whole yard with it I know
you're upset about this but this is a
place in Virginia and I love this place
I'm moving there but this town they have
a law in the books banning
trick-or-treating for anyone over 14
years old and Richards upset about it
because he trick-or-treated up until the
age of 19 right but I Got News for you
if a 19 year old showed up at my front
door with a mask on I don't give a [ __ ]
what he's up to I'm not answering the
door
i'm calling 9-1-1 a trick-or-treat
[ __ ]
didn't you used to travel by train
upstate to be dressed up as a zombie
like some guy would dress you yeah yeah
it snowed on Halloween one year and we
got stuck up there like we literally
were out in the snow because they
stopped the trains running and I'm a
werewolf and my wife was Red Riding Hood
and nobody like we were trying to even
hitchhike and nobody would pick us up I
can't believe you've lasted this long on
the show I don't know it's just
unbelievable that's the same guy who
could come up with funny [ __ ] is this
more a lot of creative people are into
weird no that's why you do it you want
to be a weirdo I don't know I do it
because I love I think he's a weirdo hi
I am Robin he's committed if he's
playing the part of a weirdo I'm going
to haunted houses and trick-or-treating
what are you doing with your life not
that like when you win on every ride at
that place you went to for three days oh
it's the best and you just went over and
over to the yeah I think they had ten
different haunted houses we went to all
ten of them all three nights so we went
to three haunted houses in total it's an
incredible waste of time no it was a
blast
look at the research that goes into this
Howard let's see do they have
jack-o'-lanterns spider wear
zombie and like you probably went
through all the houses in it in a day
you could have left but you stayed
another to Demi's yeah
was probably drinking the whole time too
didn't remember all of it
forget did we see this house eight
six-packs ago your wife's on the phone
she wants to talk about how much she
loves Halloween - hi yeah we all love
Halloween
we're at home with bubby listening to
creepy sound effect Oh bubbie loves it
right bubby
it's his favorite
Halloween's his favorite why didn't you
name your son Dracula
why don't you need me to drag Vlad
Christie Impaler Christie like Michael
Myers Christie I'm being serious red
eager Chris yeah I love it
all right why don't you all leave and
take your way
you